We tend to assume very often that there's only one way of looking at something.
One of the ways that, as a designer, I often liked to come up with my new ideas...
...is to try and look at the world in different ways.
So we think about a book.
When we first pick it up, we open the front cover and we might look at the contents page...
...to see whether there's anything interesting there for us.
And the contents page is one way of viewing the structure of a book.
Now, what this is behind me is another way of viewing the structure, actually of my book.
And that actually is a mind map of all of the content of "Change by Design".
And every important piece, every chapter, every piece of content...
...is drawn up there and linked together to show the structure.
Doing that helped me think about how I wanted to tell the story.
So it's an illustration of how, when we look at the world differently, we get to new ideas.
It's easy when you hear the word "design" to think it's about what things look like,...
...or how beautiful they are, or the latest style or product in the Museum of Modern Art, or something.
But really, what design thinking is all about is the simple conversion of need into demand,...
...need into a solution.
Any of us who went to business school, actually don't include me,...
...I went to art school, but those people who went to business school...
...were taught many effective techniques for what I would call convergent thinking,...
...which is taking the set of available choices, making, analyzing those choices...
...and making the best one, that then gets implemented.
Now that's great for taking the existing world and optimizing it.
If, on the other hand, you're trying to create new innovations,...
...there's another piece that you need to put in front of that.
And that is the creation of those choices themselves.
Because if you're just looking at the same set of choices that everybody else is looking at...
...you're likely to get to the same innovations that they are.
But if, however, you can create new choices,...
...choices that nobody else is looking at, that nobody else has seen,...
...there's a pretty strong chance you can get to an innovation that nobody else has gone to.
So successful companies innovate across a portfolio.
They do short-term incremental innovation, they do medium-term innovation,...
...and they do kind of long-term or breakthrough innovation.
And one of the tricks is applying your resources, the people,...
...the money you have appropriately across that range.